we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a caller who says if trump thinks
that by running for president again
he'll avoid getting indicted he is wrong
this is the opinion of the caller trump
is talking about
running for president to avoid being
indicted
there's no
that's not going to work
merrick garland is not going to stop any
indictments or investigations
just because he
declares that he's running for president
his only option is to move to another
country that does not
extradite
and he'd have to stay there for the rest
of his life yeah i mean listen i
generally agree
that trump running for president is not
going to prevent an indictment however
it is completely plausible that if
there's an indictment forthcoming
against donald trump and donald trump is
again the sitting president it's after
january of 2025 trump won in november 24
is sworn in in 25. and then the
indictment comes forward i do believe
that donald trump will at least have a
reasonable attempt to make to say no no
no i'm the president i can't be dealing
with this right now he used it while
president the first time around to avoid
having to testify and respond to
requests from
uh various women who had filed lawsuits
uh against donald trump so he will
absolutely do that but to the extent
that trump wants to from what we're told
get out of uh legal trouble in terms of
indictments by announcing his candidacy
i agree that that's not going to do
anything that's not going to work now
whether there's actually any um
charges forthcoming remains to be seen
we have a fantastic bonus show today
first of all
democrats forced every republican in the
house to take a stance on marriage
equality
and i know that it's july of 2022
but there are many
many
many house republicans who voted against
marriage equality secondly
joe biden has announced some incremental
climate initiatives we're going to talk
about what they are and we're going to
talk about whether they are more
substance or whether they are more fluff
this includes promoting offshore wind
uh and some other things so we will talk
about that and also the the meaning and
discussion around declaring a climate
emergency and thirdly
there's a bipartisan senate group that
has reached a deal to reform the
electoral count act this is something
we've been looking at for a while and
this relates to the circumstances that
presented themselves after the 2020
election the mike pence etc craziness
there seems to be some progress among
this senate group will tell you what is
contained there and whether it might
actually more seriously prevent what
could have happened in 2020 from even
having a shot at happening in the future
get access to the bonus show by signing
up at
joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code obama
to get a roughly 60 discount off of the
cost of membership and lastly
remember
i want you to show up to my viewer town
hall on tuesday july 26th this will be 6
p.m eastern 3 p.m pacific it'll be if
you want to watch it'll be streaming
live on the pacman live youtube channel
youtube.compacmanlive you can just watch
you don't have to participate if you'd
like to chat with me during the town
hall we will be live at 6 p.m eastern 3
p.m pacific and taking questions via
discord and of course our website
members at joinpakman.com
will get priority access with a separate
member waiting room in order to talk to
me so all great things and remember
tonight 7 p.m eastern i will be
streaming what is at least as of now
believed to be the final committee
hearing for the january 6th committee
expecting excerpts of donald trump
struggling to report his go record his
go home speech after the trump riots uh
trump's former lawyer pasipoloni
expected to testify huge tonight we'll
be live on youtube twitch and facebook
and i hope to see you then i really do